tell me how it happened how did she die  she was just standing there minding her  own business and then someone put a  bullet in her head  and animal do you work I'm scared  avi everything in silence screams to get  away from here  this place it's a cage okay no I'm not  about to make nice we new frontier as  soon as I get a moment alone with David  I'll get to the bottom of this  Clementine you were part of the new  frontier  did you know Dave I knew him you're done  here he's not a good guy  stress you monster  I'll take care of my family from now on  this is a send-off you're just seeing me  on my merry way I don't see another way  this is what David circled on the map  I think these came from Prescott there's  stuff here from the kingdom spoils from  other towns here too  don't make me do this  [Music]  you should be more careful with this  you